University and today I will talk about
the meta problem of how to improve
circular bonds this is a joint work with
Lydia and red so let's get started
I will first introduce the background of
our work including the natural proof
barrier the Black Box natural proofs and
Williams the equivalence between 1996
circular bonds and constructive
properties I'll then show you a main
serum which says that black box
constructive truths are avoidable and
I'll give you some intuition of how the
serum is proved I would very much like
to talk also about the main technical
ingredients which is the smooth strong
and low critical about PCP but I will
not go into this since I have no time
but you can check the paper for details
finally I will present some open
problems
okay the main question we are curious
about in this talk is how do we through
circular bonds
let us take for example that we wish to
prove sets does not have polynomial size
circuits how do you do that
you suppose that we have this whole
Space of functions here and we have the
language sets which have marked screen
here and we have some of the functions
in the space computable by polynomial
size circuits I marked these functions
right here
so what do we do to prove the lower box
one natural way to think of is we cut a
line such as the blue line here that
separates the green points from the
right ones if indeed the set this green
point is in the blue area and there's no
red points in the Blue Area then we can
get such it's not contained in key
search poly but this is not over for the
sake of our Stone Age human brains it is
much easier to think of a blue line if
it satisfies two additional properties
the first is largeness saying that this
blue area is not too small and the
second is constructivity it says that
this blue line is not using it's not too
complicated
why is that well you don't want the line
to be as complicated as this as this one
right I can't imagine
how we can work with such a stuff
and also if the blue area is too small
like this red over here and it's just
two ad hocus the arguments as a natural
blue lines come up with some human
should mostly satisfy these three
properties usefulness largeness and
constructivity
so this lists the formal definition of
natural proofs by restaurant rudish in
1994. throughout this talk we assume
that c is a typical polynomial size of a
cloud such as keeps such poly and C1 tc0
or ac0 here I'll write a blue line as a
productive key which is a subset of all
Boolean functions the functions in the
subset corresponds to the Blue Area here
we say it is natural against some
circuit Class C if it satisfies the
three properties usefulness largeness
and constructivity first usefulness it
says that no red points are in the Blue
Area this means that for any language l
in a circuit Class C they exists
infinitely many input lens and such as
Ln is not in a property here LM means
the language L restricted to this
specific influence app and of course
since we are proving lower bounds we
need at least one language say the
language set is in this property so
we should have the um the property p and
to be non-empty
second largeness this means that the
property PN is not only non-empty but it
is also large it contains at least one
of a poly and fraction of the functions
the original definition by Roswell is 1
over 0.2 to the N but this is not very
essential and while the poly Edge is
much more convenient for us so let's
stick to this setting and loves
constructivity blue line is simple this
means that given the choose table of a
function as inputs uh here that should
the input lenses are actually the length
of the whole choose table which is 2 to
the m this is very important so remember
keep this in mind throughout this talk
okay give given the choose table as the
input we can decide whether the function
is in the property key in polynomial
type here here I am Stars again the
input length is 2 to the F so by the
polynomial time we mean quality two to
the end time
so this is the formal definition of
natural proofs
if you can't remember the formal
definition it is completely okay you
just remember that by largeness we mean
the Blue Area covers at least one of a
poly fracture of the whole space and by
constructivity we mean that deciding
what the function is in the Blue Area
coming down in poly the length of the
truth table time
okay as we mentioned before an actual
proof is the most intuitive way of
proving a lower box and indeed most
lower bounds in the literature satisfies
these three properties but unfortunately
the drawback of being natural is being
simple the same network by restaurant
rooted showed that live show proofs are
just too intuitive and simple was to
prove super polynomial size circular
bonds so if you want to prove something
like that it's not contained in case
such poly we must go beyond natural
techniques
to be more specific
they showed if Strong's random functions
can be computed can be computable in C
then there is no natural properties you
also can see and we believe such strong
surrender functions to exist in very
weak socket classes such as formulas or
even tc0 so this means that if you wish
to Super polynomials as well balanced or
even such weeks okay classes
we will need to use some non-natural
techniques
but how how can we overcome this natural
proof barrier this usefulness should be
inherent for proving a lower bound you
can only think of getting rid of either
largeness or constructivity
by avoiding largeness we're trying to
say that specific functions like sets
are hard for special reasons so you
can't expect the property to work for a
less proportional functions
on the other hand if we try to avoid
constructivity it means that the lower
bounds such as is not containing P such
partly it's hard to prove because human
reason is
in polynomial type we need to go beyond
such Trinity reasoning to prove the
lower bonds but still the question
remains
which of the largest or constructivity
should should we avoid
Williams give us
to discussion about 10 years ago saying
that through being a super polynomial
law about actually implies a
constructive but not large property
against it in fact if you're the
equivalence between an axis and
contingency and constructive properties
here an axis not deterministic
exponential type
so it means that to prove a lower bound
such as such as an axis of company C we
cannot after all get rid of
constructivity
but now the question comes
we already know the constructivity
cannot be avoided but how strong should
the constructivity be you see the case
of even stronger nodes are
constructivity are avoidable
so this comes to the notion of Black Box
obstructivity introduced by finally I
mean the last year
the origin of initial constructivity
requires what the function is
inappropriate is disciple in poly Q to
the n-type that is polynomial to the
truth table length
maybe you can be much more ambitious
we can ask what is his disciple in
probabilistic political rhythmic time
that is polyantine
this is point as a politics because this
is prologismic to the two stable lens
now of course the constructing algorithm
cannot take the whole to stable as
inputs but it can only have all access
to some to the function X
there are some technical details for
this definition actually we must first
generalize the properties to promise
practice which is two sets Piers MPN no
and the autism is only required to
distinguish the function from being
appearing yes or piano
if the function is in needs of them then
algorithm can output anything we just
don't care
that is intuitively instead of having a
blue line
separating the red points and the green
points we have a white blue strip here
and algorithm can output either yes or
no on this trip
here and use some example to explain
what is capital Champion yes I'm here no
it's useful
suppose though you are given a sequence
of zero one bits and you are asked to
decide some properties related to the
proportion of one bits in the sequence
suppose first you are required to decide
exactly whether there are more than half
of one bits when it comes to it very
efficiently by something only a few bits
right you must read almost all the bits
they but if I only ask you to
distinguish if the number of lines is
more than two thirds or if it is
less than one third
and I don't care about your answers if
it is in between the success codes then
you can of course answer this question
very efficiently by a simple sampling so
this is the difference
is for a promise property if a function
f is in here yes then algorithm accepts
with some large probability and if the
function is in key and no then the
exciting probability is small and we
don't have a guarantee on the acceptance
probability if it is in this option just
no piano
Okay this may be a bit technical but the
key point is just the algorithm runs in
probabilistic poly and time instead of a
much slower poly Q to the end time
why is the black box constructivity is
seemingly much stronger than the
original one here I'll give you another
view let us first consider the original
constructive property useful against C
you can actually view it as some sense
of analysis algorithm for C in
researches table and tells you something
on trivia about the circuit Class C
and the Williams equivalence tells us is
that such a narrative organism is
actually equivalent to proving circular
bonds
similarly because we can say that the
left of constructive property can be
viewed as some super efficient property
taxes or example C it tells something
about C but only covering a few bits
about the function this is some sense of
property testing so this certain form of
property testing organism seems to be
much stronger than the slower analysis
algorithm
but yes it's
in this paper we'll give surprise
answers to this question okay at least
surprises us at first that this black
box constructive property are also the
certain form of property testing
algorithm is also equivalent to Circular
bonds so all this are Origins
and our intuition that level of
constructivity is much stronger to be
wrong they are actually equivalent
okay so here is the form of zero the X
is not containing C implies a black box
contract to property useful against C
and combining with Williams equivalence
all the followings are equivalent axis C
the existence of constructive property
and existence of backwards constructive
property
this tells us
to prove circular bonds we will have to
be able to show
this sense of super efficient property
testing algorithms for the circuit class
it also tells us that if we have a
constructive property which is in time
according to the m we can generally
bootstrap it into a poly endpoint
good but before we go on to the overview
of the proof let's first say a word
about the randomness in the definition
you may Wonder in the definition of
level of constructivity why is the
algorithm probabilistic
we prove that this Randomness is
actually essential
in a sense of deterministic polar time
constructivity does not exist
we also have other related results in a
paper such as a bootstrapping result on
the black person's active and also large
properties they can read all paper for
more details
okay for the rest of the talk I will
give you some intuition of how the
equivalence is proved let's first start
from Williams result in 2013. relax it's
not continuous C implies the existence
of a constructive property used against
C the proof goes in two steps first we
learn to prove that acts lower bounds
implies some sense of wind is lower
bumps that have expansion that Williams
Show the constructive property from this
windows loadback
so what is this intermediate witness
Urban it says that there is an ax star
5V
let us say that it decides the language
L such as for any Circuit Family C in a
circuit class
is a pair of inputs
there is an infinite sequence of inputs
X1 X2 X3 such that for all such x i it
is in the language L but this true
stable of c x i with X is the first
input fails to win this x i that is um
vxi with the choose table
Rejects
so the this llama actually says that NX
does not have small Circ does not have
small circuits
implies that Alex verifies do not accept
simple weaknesses
this is in fact an equivalent the other
direction of this llama is just a
well-known ether win Islam not dive into
this because it is a bit too technical I
will only use it as a Blackboard but the
second part is much more important for
us so I'll stay a bit more here in this
step we start from an Excel class do not
accepting Witnesses I want to construct
the constructive property useful against
C
the property itself is quite simple you
just take a batch input expect by a bad
input that means that all the weaknesses
of it of large circuit complexity and we
simulate the index verifier with the
choose table of the function as the
witness y that is your output is V Xbox
and the choose table a bit
this property is of course constructive
constructive but why is it useful
suppose it is not
then there is an function f in the
circuit Class C but it is accepted by
the property
this means that this function f is a
witness for expect but it is of low
circuit complexity this leads a
contradiction
there is a technical issue here of how
do we find such a bad input aspect one
way to do this is simply take the bad
input as a bus this is to a bit too we
just forget about it here so here's the
truth the running time of the property
is the same as the NX verifier so it is
polynomial in the truth table of that
now our goal is to make it poly log
logarithmic how do you do that
as someone you may already figure out
stance is to use probabilistic checkable
proofs
and let me recall here that's a PCP
verifier for NX language takes the input
X and an internal Randomness R and
access to a proof Oracle Pi it runs in
poly X type that is it only makes poly X
queries to the proof Oracle also the
proof Oracle itself may be of
exponential lens
and we have for any acts in the line in
English language L there is a truth
Oracle such as the verify accepts with
certainty but for any X not in the
language no truth Oracle will make the
verifier except with probability more
than answers
now we follow that ideas in the previous
slides but use a PCP verifier instead of
just an episode file which simulate the
PCP verify with the same fat input
expert and the function as proof Oracle
then the running time of this property
will become politicalismic to the length
of the choose table which is the length
of the proof Oracle
so this is indeed a black box
constructive property to make the
property further useful we now need the
assumption that there is a TCP verifier
whose almost Witnesses are not too
simple say not representable by C
but almost Witnesses we mean here the
proof oracles that make the verify
accept is probability close to one
so here's the outline of Our Truth we
start from an access document C and our
goal is a black box constructive
property useful against C
we still use the first step ingredients
proof which gives us a winning slowbound
for NX from the NF circular bonds
and the previous slide tells us that's
almost when its lower bounds for PCP
verifiers implies Blackboard
constructive useful properties
but they're still kept in the middle the
bottom line looks to be stronger than
the other one since PCP verifies a
special cases of Oxford files are almost
Witnesses or superset of witnesses they
only require an acceptance probability
to be close to one instead of instead of
exactly what
but actually if we use the specific TCP
with special properties
in particular a smooth strong and
locally decodable in the circuit Class C
you can make this implication true
and we are indeed able to construct such
disappears the construction is so
technical that I will not go into
details but the point is with the
construction of such PCP and this
observation that such PCP system
conserves within slow pumps we are done
okay finally I'll conclude the two
related open troubles first does such
equipments also work for super
polynomial size circuits and can the
equivalents preserve the circuit
complexity currently if you want a black
box constructive property you can see
circuits of essence sites we must rely
on the load-bound Assumption against
this circuits of much larger circuit
size can we improve this to say killed
osm
this cell allows to build much finer
equivalence instead of just saying
polynomial size
in our current technique this overhead
comes from the middle part this wind is
lower bound to PCP almost when it's
robots so it will be interesting if we
can remove such overheads
okay that's all thank you very much